all right how you doing all right hey
there chief
[Music]
anything to repo to her sprained her
ankle F near 40 mile creek yeah she was
running from a grizzly [ __ ] she right
yeah mom and cub lady must have missed
the signs but no one was attacked should
we do something put signs up I mean not
cheap it we don't just shoot bears chief
unless they make an unprovoked attack
wait hmm I'll let you know if anything
else happens you can always go fishing
this year so what the last police chief
did he left his fishing stuff over there
before he passed it up ourselves we can
kill by bear was wrong oh he was dead
from exposure by the time the Bears got
to him that's a judgment he's joking
right
yeah he's joking council couldn't afford
him chief if the careful of dark a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this town relies almost entirely on a
modest tourist industry doesn't it so if
you're so keen on protecting it why is
there a tourist in the hospital and a
grizzly bear on the loose while you were
out fishing all day seems to me that she
should be out there shooting bears not
in here shooting his mouth off
[Music]
how'd I do these always go the same way
if someone won't sign over their land
for company excess we just build our
roads on the neighbors property then
they get all the tanker noise and
traffic fumes and none of the cash what
about the rancher Lyle comes from an oil
family he'll know industry tactics then
there's a doctor with the chip on our
shoulder and the police chief with
something to prove you're here to get a
bunch of boxes ticked don't make things
complicated
[Music]
[Music]
care to film in I'm taking responsible
social action alright poisoning our
River oh it's our River now is it okay
yeah
this knife is bullet in the front room I
found it also broken window ground floor
fire damage to the downstairs bathroom
we contained it an empty briefcase on
the porch [ __ ] checking the perimeter
no good
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
stana column
the oldest beauty I don't think there's
a loo here
that's
[Music]
[Music]
no no pop sorry
he's fine
[Music]
that
you
North stream chose this site because it
is the perfect nexus for oil sands
petroleum into the u.s. demo you just
rolled in here or in here you aren't
based here although people love the
police in Canada yeah until you got here
evidently you may well have a personal
opinion about our use of the road but
you're powerless to stop it you say that
money just get here just fun look around
you need a reason murder investigation
you seriously think an oil company
killed here I can aid you in oil cotton
your only hope is to cooperate fully
with North stream oil
you're asking me to destroy this man's
family
you